hello and welcome my name is philip
bradiger
i'm a senior software engineer at iconda
and today i'll be talking about scalable
cross-filtering dashboards with panel
holoviews and the g plus
so before we dive in what is cross
filter cross filtering is the ability to
select data points in one plot
and having those selections be reflected
in other plots it's also known as link
brushing
and it really allows you to get a grip
on multi-dimensional data sets
by showing many different views of the
same data and how they relate
so particular as data sets get more
complex
and have interrelationships in many
dimensions
it's really useful to be able to kind of
drill into them
and see how different dimensions relate
to each other and that's what we'll be
seeing
today so i'll be picking apart the title
bit by bit so we're going to be starting
with today is cross-filtering
with holo views and hp in this first
example we're going to be building
interactive plots
and start with three main libraries
we're going to be using pandas
to load and manipulate the data all
views to link our selections
uh selections between the plots we
generate automatically
and hd plot to quickly generate plots
using
an api that you're familiar with so hp
plot
is very much mirrored on the pandos.plot
api
and so if you're familiar with that um
it's going to give you a very familiar
experience
but instead of outputting that button
plots which are static
hb plot generates bokeh plots which you
can interactively
uh work with so we're going to be
starting by generating a few plots
from the palmer penguin dataset which is
really nice
open source data set which was recently
open sourced in fact
which represents measurements about
various penguin species
particularly three species
are the lead penguins gen two penguins
and the third one i forget but we're
going to be seeing that in a minute
um so it has measurements about their
beaks so the length and for example
width
their flipper length their body mass
their sex and
more information and so this is a fairly
complex data set
and we might want to get a handle on how
these different dimensions relate
so we might generate a very simple plot
here we're going to be using a tree plot
so just like dot plot we can use the hp
plot
and generate a scatter plot of their
common length versus a common depth
so just as a reminder this is in fact
their beak measurements about their beak
and we're going to be coloring this by
the species
give it some fixed colors and so that
things don't
um so we can clearly distinguish them
and now we can see here we got out a
bokeh plot
that we can work with so this we can now
zoom and pan around we can hover over
the data points
to get more information about the
precise measurements for example
and their species so the third species i
forgot about before
are chin strap pancreas so this is nice
um and as a first view it clearly
distinguishes these three species
uh but we really want to dig in a little
bit deeper
so another thing we might want to do is
generate a histogram
here we're going to be generating a
histogram of their body mass
again colored by species um and we can
see here
you really have non-overlapping
distributions of body mass
and again we get an interactive plot
however information
counts in each each
each bin here and we can zoom and turn
around
okay but how do these two relate well
we can find out using this hp link
selections
function um so we can make an instance
of this and we'll see how that comes in
useful later
really we could just do this in this
particular instance
just and we're only composing the
histogram plot and the scatter plot
the plus operator in hollow views which
is what hp plot outputs
basically puts plots side by side or in
fact into a grid
which allows us to lay them out very
easily
and the link selections function
basically just
takes these objects and automatically
adds link selections to them
and so what we get here what we didn't
have in the previous plots
were these select tools so we have box
select and we have glasses selected
if we do a select performance selection
on one of the plots you can see
it reflects it's automatically reflected
in its other plot
and we can use both box and lasso select
um
a few different parts of this
distribution uh the other nice
thing is we can automatic we can select
the selection mode here
i.e this tells us how to combine
different selections on one plot
so so far we've kind of had the replace
mode where
it just replaces the current selection
we can also combine selections
that was clicking
we can also combine selections so here
for example i can add a selection
um i can combine multiple selections
um to basically get more control
alternatively
we can also get
subtract from our selections so let me
actually clear the selections
reset everything and then
we're going to select this subtraction
mode
so if i start by making a lasso
selection
which tries to include most of the
points um
oh in fact it's the inverse um so i
thought you got that wrong there
but now if i further try to subtract
from here
so for example i don't want these points
in my selection
um or this particular point here
i have now completely included the
excluded the chin strap species
so in this way we can really combine
multiple selections uh
to kind of drill down to exactly the
data points that we're interested in
and we can also combine selections
across plots so if i select on here
to for example only include higher body
masses
or exclude higher body masses we now get
just our idly species
this also works for other plot types
right so so far we've seen the scatter
plot we've seen the histogram plot
we can basically reflect the selections
in
any type of plot um
and so we can for example yeah just
select here and we can see here
in this bar plot which basically just
counts
it's a count of all the individuals in
each species
um and we can also see the distribution
here in this violin plot
which is split by 6 so we can see how
the distribution changes
as we select among other dimensions
so for example if we select only
low body mass we can kind of see
how the distribution of flipper length
also should also shifts downwards
so we're really getting at um how
one dimension relates to another image
and we can drill down as deep as we want
okay so that's pretty nice and we can
work with a variety of plot types
but we can also work with different data
types so here
we're going to be loading a data set of
air temperatures using the x-ray library
so if you're not familiar with x-ray
it's basically a multi-dimensional
pandas um you can
kind of think of it as that if you have
multi-dimensional arrays
this big in this case we have um
basically
uh measurements over the us recorded
over time so
you should think of it as a 3d array and
if we specify to entry plot that we want
to plot this as quad mesh
and you use and latitudes it realizes
there's one dimension left over here
which is the time dimension so here we
get this time slider
that allows us to scrub through this
time axis
let's see how these temperatures evolve
over time similarly
we're going to be generating a histogram
plot here and we're going to also be
grouping that over time
so that we get the distribution of
temperatures
um for a particular time point and kind
of
can select on it so again you simply
apply our link selections function here
to this composed layout of these two
plots
and if i do that so for example i'm only
interested in higher temperatures
on just below 300 to 310 kelvin
um we can see here that this selects um
here's the southern regions of the us
and
some of the gulf i think is what this is
and so now we can see how
that distribution shifts as we scrub
through this time
time dimension right
so we can really get at um
how these two variables relate and we
can also do the inverse right you can
say
well really i'm interested in a
particular region of the u.s
so for example the eastern seaboard and
i want to see
how the distribution of temperatures
there evolves over time
apply lots of select which applies that
region
and we can now see how the distribution
of temperatures changes
there over time so again
um these two plots individually are of
course useful
um but adding the ability to do link
selections really allows us to drill
down
and kind of look at subsets of the data
and see how
different variables relate to each other
in that particular
subset of data so
really at this point you should have
learned that really
uh the link selections are very general
they apply to all kinds of plot types
and basically most prototypes in all of
these and hp plot are supported
and they really let you drill down on
the data
okay so uh we've now seen what link
selections can do for us
um but part of the whole promise of this
was
that this would be scalable so how do we
scale this so so far we've
dealt with relatively small toy data
sets um but now we want to scale this up
a little bit
how do we go about this well two
libraries will come in useful here we're
gonna be
we can use das to basically scale our
panels data frames up and out to
multiple cores
or to a whole cluster um so if we can
kind of work with data sets much larger
than we could deal with on a single core
with pandas or we can use
rapid qdfs to really even move the
computation to a gpu
um so the nice thing about a35 is that
all these different libraries here you
see here
kind of feed into hp plot the dot plot
api
and you don't even need to change
anything about your code you simply
change
the data frame type so you use a pandas
data frame
or you use a graphics codef data frame
or you use a das data frame
and things just work um you don't need
to change any of your code
that then feeds into home views which is
the intermediate representation of this
and then optionally we can feed this
through data shader which allows us to
scale this to much larger data sets so
if you think about it if you were to
drop
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
millions or even billions of data points
in your browser
it would just crash and so what data
shader lets you do is
it provides a way to very quickly
aggregate our data into a tv
2d view uh so you can sort of think of
it as a 2d histogram
and then that fixed size image gets sent
to bokeh
um and we can zoom and pan around and
kind of interactively explore
data much larger than your browser could
ordinarily handle
and this is all wrapped up nicely in the
hp plug bundle
uh so what we're going to start here
with here and we're going to hide this
ugly warning
first of all uh we can see here uh we're
loading this new york taxi data set
um from a parquet file and here we're
going to be
using das to do so so this load data
function also would also support
codifs and this particular machine
doesn't have a gpu so i'm not going to
do that
or we could use pandas but to
demonstrate some of the scalability
we're going to be using desk and so in
all three cases we get back a data frame
containing 11 million data points or
11.8 million to be exact
and this could be hundreds of millions
or even billions of data points
and depending on your particular gpu or
how many chords you have or what cluster
you're scaling up to
uh this would work fine so we're quickly
also going to be looking at this data
and we can see here we have drop of
times
dates the number of passengers trip
distances pickup locations drop off
locations fair amounts
amounts so on so there's quite a bit of
data here and we might want to see how
that data relates to
right and so getting at this
with a cross-filtering view
with just a regular pawn it's kind of
difficult so what we're going to be
using here
is we're going to be using the hvp
function
in particular um so this is hidden
behind these options here
but we're going to be using data shade
equals true so this is
using data shader in the background
which aggregates our 11.8 million data
points which would ordinarily just
crash things and now we can zoom and pan
around
and even drill down to individual data
points right
but we still get this really nice
overview at the
zoomed out bubble so we can still see
all our data
it's all very interactive and this is
all scaled by desk
so this would work just the same on the
gpu only it would be even more
responsive
and so now what we're going to do is
we're going to apply a selection here
on the pickup locations
and we're going to see that get
reflected on
here this is taking a bit longer
we can see that reflected on this side
to see where people who got picked up
at the airport here i got dropped up and
we can see here there's these dense
clusters
in downtown manhattan and so and the
explanation for this
is in fact that a bunch of large hotels
here
are in downtown manhattan um so
immediately
we can kind of gather more information
than we ordinarily could
ordinarily could just by doing some
selections here
and so we can clean more information
about this data and so this
the way this works in the background is
again we've generated our plot with the
hp
plot the link selections here we've made
an instance so that we can apply the
link selections individually
to these two elements and
in the background uh basically as we
apply different operations
such as data shading um hull views keeps
the pipeline of the operations that
we've applied
and then replace those given the current
selection
right so in the background we still see
the full data set and then in the
foreground
we see a view of the current selection
um fed through the same pipeline that
the original data was
and so in that way we can basically
perform link selections on pretty much
any kind of data
and any kind of plot type including
complex plot types such as
these data shader plots you see here
so another thing we're going to be doing
here is generating a few histograms
of some other variables in this data set
so for example the trip distances
uh the fair amounts the pickup hours the
drop-off hours
and in fact some of that is quite off
here but that's okay
so now we can kind of select on
different attributes in this data set
and again
we're basically generating our plots
here we're iterating over these
hist ranges which basically tell us what
range we should aggregate
we're using http.hist
and then finally we again use the link
selections object that we defined
previously
we made an instance before we apply that
and now we get a column of histograms
that we can reuse in a little bit
so again using just very few lines of
code we've generated
quite a few views of this data and now
we get the task of laying this out
nicely
right and that's where the panel library
comes in so if you're not familiar with
panel
we're now going to be building a
dashboard that you can deploy in
different scenarios
uh the panel library is meant to make it
easy to take your exploratory workflows
and so you've done some work in a
notebook or in a script
and now you want to share it with
someone and so this is often
difficult in the past but panel makes
this easy it supports a wide
wide range of visualization types pod
types
and you can simply combine it with panel
and then prototype it in a notebook
kind of build it through that feedback
loop if i want to adjust this a little
bit i want to fix this
and finally and because panel is built
on top of okay
we can simply deploy it using the bokeh
server
so that's really nice and we're going to
dive into what that looks like a little
bit
so panel has really powerful apis and
one of those
apis is the panel depends method so
panel depends basically says
i depend on some variable and if that
variable changes
uh re-render this view um so in that way
it's reactive it's a bit like um excel
right
you find some dependency on some other
cell and when that cell changes it
updates
depends here what are we depending on
well we're going to be
depending on the selection on this data
frame
so again we're reusing the selection
link selections instance
to say giving a parameter that changes
whenever the selection changes
and then return the currently selected
data out of this data frame
and so that's what we get here we
basically get a data frame
reflecting the current selection and if
we show that we can see here
we're basically just formatting um the
total number of trips
and the selected number of trips and
then the average trip distance
um in that selection
and then um when we for example go back
a little bit
i'm not gonna just be selecting trips
um up to four miles long
all right so that's going to take a
little second because all of these plots
that we saw before
um basically were linked including
uh the plot the other plots
uh the the um geographic plots that we
saw before
and so now we can see here we've
basically selected a subset
of the data and we can see here the
average drift distance
has dropped significantly and so
as we said before um
panel supports a wide range of not just
plot types tables and so on
it also has various widgets and
indicators that allow you to indicate
various things about the data right so
here we're going to be using or maybe up
using
the progress widget which is meant to
give us some indication of progress
um to basically show the fraction of
data that we've selected
so here we can see we've selected most
of the data and it gives us a nice quick
visual indicator
and this is just using the same api that
we saw before
uh so we're depending on that current
selection
and then return this progress widget
which updates whenever we
perform any selections all right well
okay so now we've built various
uh components and we want to put this
together into a nice dashboard that we
can share
um since panel zero 10 which was very
recently released
and we now have the ability to use
so-called templates so here we're going
to be using the material template
um we're going to be giving a quick
title give it a logo
give it a theme and then we're going to
start composing
our actual dashboard right
so we're going to create a quick header
put a little spacer in there
our accounting if you remember this is
the little bit that
tells us about the number of
number of trips that were selected uh
we're going to be laying out our plots
side by side and ensure that the axes
aren't shared
and then here comes the actual composing
of the template
the template comes with some list like
objects which we can simply append to
so here we append our header to the
header object
on this template we append our
histograms to the sidebar here and then
we append
the plots to the main area and so in
just a few lines we've created this
we've populated this template with
the various components that we've been
writing up
so now we're going to be switching to
that
deployed version so here
i basically set dot show which basically
launches a bucket server
and opens it in another tab um
alternatively we could be using servable
here
and this would basically mark it so that
on the command line
we can run this with panel serve and
then point it to this notebook
so in just a line of code we can make
this whole thing deployable
and so if we look at that um yeah maybe
we're gonna have to rerun this
take a little second um but basically
the panel
architecture makes it easy to kind of
prototype and play around in the
notebook
compose different plots and then plug it
into this nice little template
which we can deploy and view
okay so now we've opened this dashboard
we can see here this is really
uh quite a nicely laid out dashboard we
get our sidebar
which we can collapse everything is
responsive
and we see our trips here we see
our geographic plots here so once again
we could kind of
select some subset of the data again i'm
going to select here
on the airport
and see what that selection looks like
uh now we can see the distributions here
in history rooms here update to reflect
that selection
and so that's quickly gives us an idea
of
how uh trips here in the at the airport
uh differ from trips otherwise right
and so we can for example see the trip
distances are much longer from the
airport which makes a lot of sense
uh we can again see the distribution
here change quite a bit
and so on so we could further narrow
that down and say really
uh well i'm only interested in really
low fares
so four to six dollars where did people
go
from the airport on ford from two to six
dollars
and so again make sense uh only very
short distances show up now
um very short distances here
um i think i kind of broke the selection
so we're going to reset
this what you probably can't see here is
also that we get a little
progress indicator but i'm probably
currently just hovering over my own
image
so that's fine um so
yeah just within a few lines of code we
generated this really quite complex
dashboard
um from our
the components that we defined in our
notebook
all right uh at this point i really need
to thank
the organizers of this conference um i'm
sure it's
i'm very excited for various talks i
also need to thank john neese who
implemented
the first version of link selections and
i'm really looking forward to your
questions in the
q a sessions thanks very much
i hope you learned a lot and
please try out our tools thanks very
much